My husband's birthday is coming up,
so I decided to surprise him by cooking him an Italian
inspired dinner tonight.
Started by making some mozzarella cheese
for my tomato and mozzarella salad.
Combine some milk with citric acid and some run it
before slicing it up and returning it back to the heat.
Once all the way separates from the curds,
spoon them into my cheese cloth and let them drain
before returning them to some hot water and shaping my mozzarella.
Once that was done,
I moved on to deflating my focaccia dough
that had been rising for about four hours.
I turned it out and let that rise for another hour
while I got started on my pasta dough.
This was very simple.
It was just some flour,
eggs, olive oil, and salt.
I needed that until it was smooth
and then wrapped it up in plastic wrap.
One night I threw together this random fennel and leak pasta,
and ever since then, my husband has been asking me to make it again.
So today was the day I finally sliced up some leak and fennel.
For setting that aside this point,
my focaccia dough was ready to get dimpled and popped in the oven.
So I opted to make a cumin seed and lemon focaccia.
I put that in the oven and then got started on shaping my pasta.
We went for a simple fettuccine shape today,
and I put all of my pasta on my drying Rack to dry
before I prepped my salad.
I used some heirloom tomatoes,
the mozzarella I made earlier,
a drizzle of olive oil,
salt, pepper, and basil.
I sliced up my focaccia
and plated that before I moved on to finishing my pasta.
Sauteed my leek and fennel with some garlic and a splash of white wine
before adding my pasta into my sauce and slowly ladling that pasta
water and Parmesan cheese in to make a sauce
before plating it all up
and finishing it with some Parmesan cheese on top.